If you love historical mysteries, but wish they weren't.
So European switch the settings to easy mode for a scavenger hunt that anyone
could figure out.
Even kids and Americans national treasurer.
When the declaration of independence is in danger, someone's.
Going to steal the declaration of independence. One.
Group will steal the declaration of independence.
There's still a declaration so that.
No one else can steal the declaration of independence.
I'm not going to let you steal the declaration of independence.
And use it to re steal a bunch of treasure that America already stole equal or
Mizuno that's American for funders keepers, meet Benjamin Franklin Gates,
the lease settle name for the most subtle Nick cage character.
Who's basically Ross Geller. If you were a professional America knower,
but who solves puzzles like he's the world's greatest detective Adam West
Batman.
The legend and the key. There is something,
a map maps have legends maps have keys,
make a dishonest shortcake library.
Clearly a corrupted version of a word library. The map said here at the wall,
spelled a two is wall street falls,
the path of an actual wall that the original Dutch sellers built as a defense to
Maingate was located. A street called to here also two weeks.
When is the time of the clock?
Like the whistle of the train when it's tilted too.
Hang on. This movie is about the Freemasons.
And this movie was produced by Jerry Brooke, hover,
who also made the rock where Sean Connery plays. John Mason, Connery con.
Ornery, ornery, Khan, logging, old people, and one old person,
Lord general, humble, who is played by ed Harris, con Harris con air,
which is also produced by Bruckheimer and stored Nicholas cage.
And the villain was Cyrus. The Firuz coronavirus, a con in the air,
wake up sheeple.
But to pull off the highest of the bicentennial,
this walking pub trivia night is going to need a kick crew.
So he's bringing along this one nerd. He knows everything.
I'm tracking it through the GPS and Charlotte's phone,
daylight savings wasn't established until world war II.
I could just shoot warning that we end here.
It could be that the hydrothermal properties of this region produced hurricane
force ice.
Until it's funny for him to not know anything.
Okay? What's not endorsed cipher. Do you know what the preservation room is for?
Delicious jams and jellies? What do we do with them? We look through it.
Together. They'll rope. One more person into their skiing. A Woolworth woman.
Very cute man, who spends the entire movie being told to shut up.
And can you please stop shouting?
You're still shy. Quiet please. Now, shush.
She really can't shut her mouth gantry. Shut up please.
She's the one calling all the shots. Now she won't shut up.
Until she rewards our heroes. Patriotic tune writing with a mat to her vagina.
Where does it lead to you'll figure it out. Oh,
the real national treasure was inside her all along strap in for an
action packed mandatory high school field trip.
As the movie gives our nation substitute teachers enough,
Ben Franklin facts to excuse at least five smoke breaks.
Do you actually know who the first person to suggest daylight savings one.
And fills in the rest of the run time with generic shootouts and explosions
until the day is Sayed.
Thanks to skills you learn from your real history teacher video game.
[Inaudible].
So enjoy a movie that blows loads for America Bruckheimer style.
That'll take you back to simpler times where our only adversaries were blonde
Euro.
Hong's trying to steal our coin collections and the secret cabal who robbed
other cultures, ran the country in secret and hold.
The highest positions in law enforcement was like a super cool,
good thing that any kid would be happy to join to you.
So swear. So sweet.
Oh, I want to be in the deep state story.
Indie Alex Jones, the DaVinci doctor,
girlfriend surprised mother one does not simply walk into the national archives.
The Wolf historians being reckless with priceless artifacts.
Don't don't break it.
I found the Charlotte. You mean she was a ship here and she was.
Beautiful.
Sassy black glary. We take visa. Doesn't look like,
do you want some?
And the only time Nick cage gets to Nick cage.
That's it. Okay. It's over.
Red, white and blues glues.
Do a bunch of guys with them.
And tools build all this. So when they built the pyramids,
the great wall of China slaves.
I'm the holiday Alma Domo.
Here's my body fit and pure.
Now you're black and souls. Oh, cure coffee,
or need or kill you. I with Gugu Gaga.
I hate movies. No, I don't.